elle ne supportait plus d'être battu une
sexagénaire comparez donc depuis ce
matin aux assises de loire est pour le
meurtre de son époux un homme qui
l'aurait violentée
selon la défense pour la cour en fait
toute la question est de savoir s'il ya
eu ou non préméditation préméditation
elle d'acadie jean pierre bru son c'est
une femme simple qui se présente à la
barre devant les jurés jacqueline
sauvage de son nom de jeune fille 65 ans
comparaît libre sous contrôle judiciaire
elle est accusée d'homicide sur norbert
marot son mari pendant 47 ans 47 ans de
vie commune marquée par des violences
physiques et des humiliations sur elle
mais aussi sur leurs enfants le 10
septembre 2012 à la selle sur le bief
près de montargis jacqueline abba
norbert marot son mari de trois coups de
fusil de chasse il venait pour la énième
fois de la frapper pour la partie civile
qui ne souhaite pas s'exprimer l'acte
était prémédité car jacqueline et
chasseuse faux affirme l'avocat de la
défense
sa cliente a répondu à une impulsion
elle dit j'ai eu comme un éclair dans la
tête
ce passage à l'acte c'est quelque chose
qui s'est produit sans avoir de
raisonnement derrière
d'ailleurs ce que je plaiderai a indiqué
qu'ils avaient une préméditation je
dirais qu'il n'ya aucune préméditation
et nous discuterons des conditions dans
lesquelles il a été rappelé qu'elle leur
avait préparé les munitions du jour
avant ce qui me paraît ce qui ne paraît
pas établi jacqueline sauvage encourt la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
verdict mardi prochain
[Musique]